dreamer would you dream
i saw lex as the anti-monitor he was
destroying every planet in existence
what kind of emotions are you going
through with the final season being on
air
oh i mean i started writing a comic book
if
that tells you that i'm not ready to let
it go i'm like goddamn
i'm not dead i'm afraid we haven't time
for any last words dream girl
streamer we're approaching the end of of
nia's
hero journey you know she's it's kind of
that final step you know she's kind of
coming back where she started but
changed and she's grown and she's
learned
and especially this season we're seeing
her learn more about her powers than she
ever has we're
seeing some you know maybe potentially
dangling threads being wrapped up in her
story
and so we're starting to see her you
know kind of um
tie up these loose ends dreamer was such
an important character to so many people
especially for the queer community she
is the first trans superhero
you included on television um that
really
is groundbreaking and that will go down
in history
dreamers meant everything i think she
holds such a special place in my heart
because
of course just being on the show in the
first place was so life-changing for me
perhaps it's inappropriate but i feel
such like an intense
i'm not ownership but like i'm so
protective
over her and i feel like i've kind of
become like her momager
almost like i feel like emails and like
her schedule and i'm like
okay so after supergirl we're gonna do
the eight page comic and then we're
gonna do this and then we're gonna do
that and it's gonna be great and you're
gonna be the next harley quinn
like i'm just like well because i'm you
know i'm
realistic i mean listen dreamer could be
the next harley quinn
i want to see a dreamer harley team up
are you kidding me
how would be first of all how queer
would that be
super queer super queer second it'd be
so fun
how excited are you that this character
that you've portrayed for so many years
now
is finally making her debut i wanted
to shout from the rooftops when they
asked me um
because of course i'm i'm writing it too
so that so i'm really really excited
about it it's
going really well i sent in my script a
couple weeks ago and it was approved
for dreamer i think a lot of her
[Music]
money mentality came from
being the first trans superhero on tv
and so with her i didn't really want to
do a story that was focusing on her
queerness or or her transness or like
coming out or anything
i wanted to do the story that was
focusing on her being a superhero
because
that is the big deal for her character
it's just being a superhero i
cannot express how cool this is when i
first saw the uh
the cover art that jim lee did i i mean
i sent him a message
like in full tears i was like you don't
know what this means and then seeing her
next to
kate kane and poison ivy and harley
quinn
and it it it was so seeing her up there
with them
is spectacular and
so so crazy to me i think i already know
the answer to this but
if there was ever an opportunity for
dreamer to have her own
spin-off would you be interested in
being a part of that
of course every day in my house from
7 30 to 9 30 i just sit on my couch with
my phone waiting for somebody to call me
so for you to have spent so many years
with this
cast would you say there's a bond or a
friendship that like
you are going to miss the most when the
series wraps
katie is going to be really hard to not
be in close proximity to just
she's really the first person that i
really really bonded with
um on this show you know my very first
week she took me out to lunch just to
make sure i had a friend
she's really really become a sister to
me and i'm really gonna
you know miss not being just
close to her being in the same city as
her
last time we chatted you revealed to me
that you are a massive
fan of rupaul's drag race as am i
are you watching season 13 and who are
you rooting for
so yes i am watching season 13 because
that's what we do staz comes over and we
do mario kart
and then we watch drag race this is like
my dream friday it is so much fun
it is so much fun so who are you rooting
for i need help
i'm torn i kind of love them all like i
haven't been able
i've been in love with rose since that
first um
x's and o's lip sync so i love rose i
mean
simone is just
hilarious and then got mick i'm just
such a fan of and i i mean the way
he paints and just and then the
attention to deep and then he's
funny on top of all of that i mean the
paris hilton snatch game
was legendary and
candy muse is just hilarious
and i from the second she walked into
the work room
i was like oh
she's one to watch this feels like one
of the seasons
where i'm almost okay with any of them
winning
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos